hello everybody and welcome to another
money-making guide today we'll be
showing you something that is pretty
well known but I was struggling with for
quite a while and it's pretty easy
method to make about 600 k2k
800 K an hour while training mage you do
get about 20-30 K magic experience as
well and what we're gonna be doing is
killing lava dragons now there's
definitely a bunch of wrong ways to do
this in a couple ways that were decently
well and I'll show you what I found to
be the easiest way to kill them and yeah
let's jump into it so to start off what
I'm going to be bringing is just the
most bare-bones gear I can really find
so a blue wizards had a mean of glory
mystic robe top and bottom mystic boots
and he tried to know this seize now I
should have a god cape and I should have
a try that into swamps but I don't so
for the sake of this guide I mean we
going with the most bare-bones that gear
possible now for the inventory I'm just
bringing some lobsters as well as a
game's necklace to teleport to the
corporal beast on top of that we're also
going to bring telekinetic grab runes
because that is going to be important
for the way that we are going to collect
our drops and all we really need is 75
magic and maybe some defense levels and
43 prayer just to avoid be cares because
there are a lot of them and you might
need it so it is pretty easy to get to
the lava dragons all you're going to do
is use your game's necklace in teleport
to the corporal beast from there you can
exit the cave be mindful that you will
be entering the wilderness from there
going to run all the way north up to the
lava dragon fortress or whatever it's
called and we're going to go right by
the agility sign as we're going to
actually safe spot them from okay so we
made it here and now there's a couple
dragons to choose from I go for this one
over here to the right of the agility
sign it tends to stay in the same spot
and while there are others around that
you can shoot they walk around and then
you di go elements just pretty annoying
and now because we're on the side of the
wall or the moat lava moat we are much
less likely get PK dove
here and the couple hours I've been
doing this I did not die once while I
was on the other side I died many times
so once the kill has been acquired you
were just going to tele grab all the
loot you could walk over the agility
shortcut if you had the Diaries done in
the agility level but I find it just a
lot easier to Telegraph the drops only
takes a minute and there we go guys
that's an easy 45 K so we're going to go
ahead and do this for an hour and see
how much money we managed to make all
right guys so after a pretty good start
we just got here and there someone who
just died on the ground over here a
little telegraph the important drops um
that being said I should have a loading
bag I just don't so I'm hoping I get as
a drop from the lava dragons if not
speak not that big a deal because I
don't want to stack up a lot of items
anyway so for our first inventory the
full loot is worth about 82 K now we
didn't get any rare drop or not rare
drops but mainly we're looking for onyx
bolt tips because each I had dropped is
worth 100 K for those that's what we're
looking for and the consistent money is
in the dragon hides and the dragon bones
our second inventory is worth a 3k so
very similar to the first and our so
looking for those onyx bolt tips our
fourth inventory is worth a little bit
more 97k we got a fire orb drop this
time but still consistent but nothing
amazing it the next loot is about the
same
86 K nothing at all this time I will got
blood runes but we're still hoping to
get some onyx bolt tips it looks like
you should get on average 36 per hour so
hopefully our luck will kick back in
alright guys there we go we got two
drops of the onyx bolt tips that is
boosting our our run to about 300 K
nearly and on top of that we also did
get a room full helm which is nice and
for our final run we actually got
another two onyx bolt tips which is
amazing that brings us to 48 onyx bolt
tips in total in another 300 K adding to
our total loot
and that's what it guys so we managed to
kill roughly forty lap dragons a little
bit more maybe in the one hour we used a
pretty much exactly 1000 charges on our
toxic reading of the Seas and will draw
all the loot now and now we didn't die
at all which is pretty awesome because
I'm used to dying a lot of dragons that
being said that Venna natus or not been
in that video on that trolled us quite a
bit so I would recommend if he is near
you definitely just half worlds because
his pain yeah stood died to him which
did happen to me so hopefully you can
learn from my mistake
now we do have to withdraw the room
crossbow and the mountain sure if I'm
forgetting anything we got the black D
hide and the coins but I think that's
about it so we'll do a price check and
actually see how much we made in the
hour all right guys we have everything
in our inventory which is what to do a
price check here obviously the notable
drop is the onyx bolt tips obviously
didn't get a visit or anything but it
looks like we're going to get about a
mil in items from that one hour of
course we'll have to subtract the
trident charges and maybe some room
costs as well but one mill in an hour
pretty good so we'll go ahead and sell
it on the grand exchange and subtract
our costs and see how much we actually
made alright guys so we sold everything
and we're left with one point one mil so
a little bit more than we thought on top
of that we do have to take off the cost
of the Trident is the main cost so taken
off about 450 K 400 K leaves us with
about six hundred and fifty K in profit
which is pure profit on top of that we
got 30k magic experience and yeah hope
you guys enjoyed and I'll see you guys
in the next video
[Music]